we're about to put the spotlight on one
special person who's in our audience
who's got some good news to celebrate
but she has absolutely no idea this is
coming because
it's a surprise shout out
[Applause]
we love a surprise and we're looking for
two besties in our audience today where
are dolores and bunny
where are you
well hello delores hello hi bunny
dolores
you nominated bunny why don't you tell
everybody
why
did you really
no bunny is it special person i'm good
just awesome she has
such a zestful life that is
uncomparable
no one deserves to be celebrated as she
does her retirement so you knew this in
june as a new york city public school
teacher
[Applause]
and now she has been promoted
to part-time nanny to a two-year-old
grandson and three
identical triplet granddaughters oh wow
effective december
what is it that
is inside of you that's so giving to
others oh that's a tough question i
don't know i just love it i love kids i
love i've always loved kids i knew since
i was in third grade i wanted to be a
school teacher
and i knew i wanted to teach special ed
i just love children
was there anything that like happened to
you in school that was the catalyst for
making you want to be a teacher or was
it just an inherent feeling
you know i think it was
teachers that i saw growing up that
wanted to help
and
just they gave everything they got and
then i saw the ones that didn't want to
and made me want to do different
and i kept saying i never want to be
like that i want to be the teacher that
everybody loves oh and she is
[Applause]
you're a grandmother of three
five actually five that's right because
wait five i thought i have an 11 year
old granddaughter
i have um a two-year-old grandson from
my daughter and then she had identical
triplet girls in june right oh my gosh
so your daughter has four now she has
four okay that's what it was that i read
wow what's it like having three newborns
right there the best thing that you
could ever have
come on i can't tell you how wonderful
it is
okay so dolores i'm so glad that you did
this and um rossi you take this well
bunny okay here's the deal we wanted to
make the congratulations last a little
bit longer so we got you a little gift
okay it's a bag a little basket of
goodies in here
it's like a spa day we put a little
flower beauty in there
and that's not all okay you can now head
to haven spa in soho where you're gonna
get
and fifty dollars in spa treatments to
count
i can't think of anyone more deserving
[Applause]
wow well i can say that as someone who
tries to march in the army of optimism
you're blowing my mind and it's just you
are amazing
let's march together
yeah
and you're going to need a little
massage after changing all those diapers
okay
diapers at a record speed i bet you can
now and any kind the wet one's the dirty
one
with you that was such a like amazing
part of having babies i just it's just
such a delightful time
and you're such an amazing person so
dolores thank you so much thank you and
thank you for giving me this opportunity
to celebrate her retirement
and promotion in his order
that's why we call it a surprise shout
out no one knows
[Applause]
[Music]
you